hello readers today we're going to talk
about making connections so I don't mean
to brag but I have at least one friend
I'm kind of a big deal I have friends at
work friends from the schools I attended
friends in my apartment building in my
neighborhood friends from places I used
to live each friend is connected to me
in some way maybe we mem the elevator or
on the train or at the community garden
in some cases I introduced my friends
and now they're friends with each other
and even hang out without me each friend
is connected to me or to each other in a
different way and for a different reason
and just in the way that people can be
friends with each other ideas can be
friends with each other to understanding
how ideas and a text connect to each
other and to the topic of the text will
help me understand what I'm reading good
readers make connections between ideas
in a text when I look at a passage I ask
myself what do all these sentences have
in common how are they connected let's
explain with a brief passage about
building ships long ago shipbuilders
used iron nails and bolts because iron
was easy to find they soon learned the
disadvantages of using this metal on a
boat iron quickly rusts and decays
especially near the salty ocean they
switched to using brass which lasts
longer I want to use this paragraph to
describe three common ways authors show
connections comparison cause-and-effect
and sequence comparison what's the same
or different between two ideas so it's
similar between brass and iron is one
example we can say okay both of these
are metals and both were used in
shipbuilding now what's different
between them
well iron rusts quickly in the ocean and
it does so faster than brass right brass
lasts longer now let's talk about cause
and effect how does one event or idea
cause another event or idea well what
happens when you put a ship with iron
bolts into salt water it rusts and
decays the ocean causes the iron to
corrode and rust so what did
shipbuilders do as a result they switch
to using brass and finally sequence what
order did things happen in now the
paragraph begin
with long ago and talks about iron
before it talks about brass it then
describes how shipbuilders switched to
brass so iron came first in the sequence
so when I read this passage on
shipbuilding even though it is very
short I'm able to make a lot of
connections between ideas doing this
deepened my understanding and helps me
to become a better reader now not every
sentence or idea is connected to every
other sentence or idea just like not
every single one of my friends is
friends with all of my other friends and
that's okay too our goal is to think
about how those sentences connect to the
topic overall think about the big
picture understanding the connections
between sentences is one of many ways
you can strengthen your skills as a
reader you can learn anything
Dave it out